Hi, I'm Stephen Jarvis and I'm Co-Master with Pac-46 and Fayetteville Arts & Saw.
This edition of the Scout-Master podcast is sponsored by backers like me.
Thanks, Clark.
And now to you, Scout-Master.
Did I ever tell you that I was once an archery merit badge instructor?
I was. Yeah, I had to give it up, though.
There were just too many drawbacks.
Okay, then, This is podcast number 201.. Hey,
Hey,
Welcome back to the Scout-Master podcast. This is Clark Green.
Let's take a look at the mailbag. We heard from Alan, who had this to say:
in podcast number 189,, Cameron Smith, who is a Scout-Master in Modesto, California,
asked why Scout-Masters tend to grow beards.
I had my answer right away:
Scouting is an outdoor program,
Okay, And when we go hiking for several days, our beards grow.
So the beard tends to show you're an outdoors kind of person,
In other words, you're a scouter.
I'm a commissioner on the High Adventure Team and I grew my beard out
near the beginning of 2013..
I agree, Alan, I think you got it.
Maybe that's right. Maybe that's the way it works.
Scouters go out on a week-long backpacking trip or something like that
and grow a beard, and you know, I've seen that happen before.
but usually the beard goes away once they come home and their wife sees it.
So
If I had a nickel for every.
You know, I've been out on those trips before, on those long High Adventure trips,
and my fellow Scouters they've let the beard go and I've said,
are you going to keep the beard once you go home?
Yeah, I certainly am.
I think it's time to grow a beard.
I'm going to let it grow out.
Then at the next meeting they're clean-shaven because they went home
and the family got to look at it.
So anyway, thanks for being in touch. Alan
Merrill von Especk is a Scoutmaster with Troop 581 in Utah
and he wrote in to say
thank you for putting together this plethora of scouting information.
It's been invaluable.
I was a committee member for many years in my current unit
because they needed somebody to fill an empty spot in the recharter.
That's how a lot of people get started, Merrick.
That's the way it works.
I became the Scoutmaster in April of this year.
Now I'm an Eagle Scout and my father was a Scoutmaster for nine years
but evidently I didn't take very good mental notes
because I can't remember much of what he did
And it's been a little bit of a struggle to get the program going
At our October roundtable. the topic was running a boy-led troop
And shortly after that I discovered your podcast
and started listening as I drove to and from work.
The podcast back up and build on the information I learned at roundtable.
I'm not a stranger to the concept of a boy-led troop.
I've been involved with the NYLT program here in our council
and I was a course leader this last summer.
But I guess I really didn't realize what we were teaching.
The light bulb was installed and I knew how it worked,
but it just never got turned on until that October roundtable
and discovering scoutmastercgcom.
Thank you so much for the time you put into the site
and the information you pour into the blog and the podcast.
I've downloaded them all and have started re-going through
the podcast in chronological order.
I have a lot of catching up to do,
but I know it'll be a great adventure.
Well, thanks so much, Merrick.
Thanks for getting in touch with us
And thanks for listening.
I'm always happy to hear that what we're doing is useful.
So it is the holiday season
and that's going to abbreviate the podcast
a little bit this week and next,
But we're still moving forward with lots of great stuff
because of our scoutmastercgcom backers,
One of the things that's going to be happening
over the next couple of weeks is a pretty good overhaul
of the website at scoutmastercgcom.
Look for a modified website design
that will hopefully help everybody find the resources
there a little bit easier,
And I'm working on a couple of things right now
that is going to bring some additional sources of information
and discussion and inspiration in the next couple of months.
So keep listening and keep your heads up.
I really can't talk in specifics now,
but I think these are going to be very valuable resources
for all of us.
Now a lot of regular readers or listeners
who find the information and the ideas offered
on scoutmastercgcom and on the podcast helpful,
have lent a hand to help keep things up and running
by becoming a scoutmastercg backer
and making a one-time payment to go towards the expenses
of producing and publishing the blog posts,
the podcast and the videos,
And so this past week
we've got four new backers to welcome.
Thank you to Tom Hasler, Dan Budd, Dave Smiley
and Kevin McIntyre.
I appreciate your interest and support.
Thanks for making this possible and helping us keep on
keeping on
Within the past couple of weeks,
we've been talking about the Scoutmaster CG app,
which is available for Android phones and tablets,
as well as iPhones and iPads.
Just over a thousand of you are using the app now,
which is really amazing.
I'm so happy that people are finding that useful.
You can find it on Google Play and in the iTunes App Store
And this week's podcast and scoutmaster ship,
in seven minutes or less,
a little holiday gift for you.
And then we have some email questions to answer
and that's going to take up the rest of the podcast.
So let's get started, shall we?
Scoutmaster ship in seven minutes or less.
Scouts forget a lot of things.
They forget their water bottle,
They forget their sleeping pad,
They forget food.
They forget a lot of things when they go camping,
and they usually forget to do one pretty important thing,
And that is to say thank you.
Now we're not doing what we do as Scouters
So that Scouts will come up to us and say thank you
or shower us with gifts or praise or anything like that.
I mean, if we were doing it because of that,
most of us would be probably be pretty disappointed
in the result.
But Scouts do say thank you in a lots of ways
that you just have to listen for because-
because it's rarely going to be coming straight up to you
with a hearty handshake and a pad on the back.
Now, most of the time, it's just in the way
that they live their lives
and in the effect that your work has on them.
Now, Baden Powell said that Scouts should not expect
life to be a bed of roses,
and he said that there probably would be no fun in it
if it was.
We're all going to come up against discouragement
and we're all going to have setbacks and disappointments,
But facing down the difficulties
is where we really end up finding the greatest satisfaction,
isn't it?
It's usually where we accomplish the greatest work
and make the most difference
When nothing seems to be working,
when nothing comes out as you planned.
take heart,
I mean, you have no idea
what your work as a Scouter will do
in the lives of the Scouts you serve.
Now here's where I'd like to tell you some
inspirational story about overcoming adversity,
or how a stone dropped in a pond makes ripples,
or something like that.
But I'm not going to do that
because you've heard all those stories already.
The message is simple:
You matter
and the work that you're doing matters.
Now. you may influence the course of history,
or you may just make your little corner of the world
a bit brighter,
But the scale of the results
does not affect the importance
of who you are
and what you do.
So I'm going to encourage you to work hard,
Give a little more,
go a little further.
It may be that that next half-step
is what really matters,
what really brings success.
I'm going to tell you not to expect anything,
but to expect everything.
If we tie the work that we do as Scouts
to rewards,
we're going to be discouraged
if they don't show up.
Do the work
because it's the right thing to do.
That's reason enough
And you will be rewarded.
You will be rewarded
because you've made the world a better place.
Your rewards aren't coming to you
wrapped in fancy paper
and tied with a bow.
They may not be coming to you
in a frameable certificate
to put up on your wall
and another patch,
But they're there.
Do good work,
Be nice,
Be faithful,
Be honest,
Reach deep down
and find the compassion
and the understanding and love
you know is there,
and keep going on.
When the choice is between
being angry or helpful,
choose helpful.
When the choice is between
being judgmental
or being understanding,
be understanding
Above all,
catch the spirit of scouting,
and that spirit is simple:
It's the love
of our fellow human beings
and the natural world
and the author of it all.
Some people call that author God,
Some people call it by other names.
There's one important thing.
It's tapping into that source of power
and love and compassion
is how we best serve our scouts
and each other.
We do good work as scouters.
We make a difference.
Never doubt it
and thank you for doing it.
Good that you do.
Welcome back to you,
It don't cost very much.
Find me a letter,
Send it by name
Email. that is folks.
And here's an answer to one of your emails.
Ladies and gentlemen,
the story you are about to hear is true,
Only the names have been changed
to protect the innocent.
That's right.
We're withholding the name
on this particular email
to protect the innocent.
Anyway,
I'm going to give you an answer
to this particular email.
anyway.
The author said:
I've been a new scout master for less than a year
and the troop I took over is a great one,
with almost 25 years
and several dozen Eagles in their history.
A scout brought to my attention
that our troop policy on boards of review
may need to be adjusted.
Our process is that
once I've had a scout master conference
and signed the scouts book.
I notify the committee that the scouts
eligible for a border review
and then we ask the boy
to do one of two things.
one: tender foot to second class,
He has to contact the advancement chair
so a board of review
can be scheduled.
If he's from first class to life,
he needs to contact three adults
off a list that is provided
out of 16, plus parents
that are trained in conducting boards of review,
to schedule the meeting.
Our thought that this is a good practice for a scout
and it provides needed experience
interacting with adults and scheduling.
It also follows our idea
of not doing what a scout should do.
This has been a practice in the troop going back
probably about 15 years
and three different scout masters.
I've been catching up with all your podcasts
and I'm almost listening to them all.
I recall one podcast where this was discussed
and that others handle
setting up boards of review in a similar fashion.
So now I have a scout
ready for his first class
board of review and he sent me an email
quoting from the 2013
guide to advancement.
the scout master does not have the authority
to expect a scout to request
or organize a board of review,
and that a scout has no
part in selecting any board of review members.
I've learned a lot from you, Clark,
and I'm looking for some guidance.
How does your troop handle scheduling
boards of review? What we do is
we have a board of review scheduled once a month.
That's the troop meeting
directly after our monthly
camp out. That's dedicated
to the patrol leaders council
meeting and a board of review
and scout master conferences.
It's kind of an administrative night.
I've been encouraging our advancement committee
not only to have boards of review
for scouts who are advancing
but to invite scouts who are not advancing
so they have a board of review
at least twice a year.
Now this hasn't quite caught on yet,
but I'm told they're working on it.
All we need to know from a scout
is that he will be attending
and you know what. sometimes they show up,
but I typically conduct a scout master conference
directly before
they go to a board of review.
I think you've got an excellent theory.
Scouts should learn to schedule things
and put themselves forward. So why do you think
that the BSA policy
is actually
180 degrees from this good
idea that you have?
Now, I'm not implying any ill will
or bad intentions on your part
or on the part of anyone involved.
I'm sharing my own experience
and my evolution on the subject.
I'm not saying that what you are doing
doesn't work or it's misapplied
or that it's a particularly bad idea,
but it's
obviously outside the policy.
There's a pretty slight adjustment on your part
to fix it, and I've made
many such adjustments over the years.
What I thought was a good idea
wasn't, and I worked to understand
and align things with the policy,
Not because I was fearful of reprisals
if I didn't, but because I wanted
to understand why the policy was
the way it was.
Perhaps you'd agree with me that the problem
with the idea of making Scouts responsible
for scheduling a border review
is because the border review
is not really their responsibility.
It's a responsibility
of the advancement committee.
I'm not saying that your troop does,
but it's not hard to imagine
how requiring Scouts to initiate
a border review request
could be misapplied
or a stumbling block,
and this is sadly true in some unit.
If you read section 8
of the Guide to Advancement 2013-
and I gotta say that section 8
puts me in mind of the old TV show MASH,
so you know. tell me folks
that you know what I mean, so I don't feel
too terribly old here,
but if you read that section
you'll see that many stumbling blocks
are eliminated. The idea behind this policy
is
to eliminate some of the negative
happening around boards of review.
People have boards of review and if the
scout shows up without a handbook
or a uniform or an improperly filled out
border review request form,
they deny them the border review
and, depending on how frequently
boards of review are scheduled,
this could set a boy back many months.
So these stumbling blocks,
these aren't the spirit of scouting.
these aren't what we want to do,
and the policy reflects
the spirit of what we want to do.
We want to encourage them
and be nice to them, right?
we don't want to put stumbling blocks
in their way or make things difficult.
I hasten to repeat: I'm not accusing
you of doing this,
but I know that it happens
and that's why the policy
is the way that it is
and why we want to follow
the policy.
Unfortunately, there's a lot of subtly
aggressive things that men
my age do to scouts
because apparently we want them
to suffer a little bit.
maybe it's because some of us had harsh
taskmasters in our youth
and difficult rites of passage
and we think that that's the way things ought to be
now. I used to be that way myself,
but thank goodness, I've learned that
becoming a welcoming and compassionate
and understanding person
makes me stronger
and not weaker, and makes the scouting
experience better
and not worse.
I hope that helps.
if you have a question for me,
you can get in touch and you're going to find out
how to do that in just a moment.
Well, thanks so much
for listening to this
200 and first edition
of the scoutmaster podcast.
here is how to keep in touch:
go to the blog
at scoutmastercgcom
and, while you're there, you can subscribe
to receive updates to the blog
by email.
you can subscribe to the blog
by email,
by email.
you can subscribe to the scoutmasterpodcastitunes
or access the podcast on your mobile device
through Stitcher Smart radio.
but better yet, join
the 1,000 plus people who are
using the Scoutmaster CG app.
e can get it on Google Play
for Android devices
or at the iTunes
App Store for your iPhone or iPad.
you can experience the wonders of
Scoutmaster CDcom through the vast panorama
of social media outlets.
Join the 4,615 folks who like Scoutmaster blog on Facebook.
tweet along with the chorus of 911 tweeters on Twitter.
pin the Pultritudinous pictures proffered publicly
with 1,200 public profile pinners on Pinterest.
Woo, watch us, if you dare, at ScoutmasterCG on YouTube
and join the 400 odd folks who form
the exclusive ScoutmasterCG circle on Google+.
Now, listen, if you can't face Facebook,
if Twitter makes you better,
if you have no interest in Pinterest,
if you don't put the? U in YouTube,
if you are a minus on Google+, that's all right.
Bunky, zoom into the late 90s and send me an email.
My email address is Clark at scoutmastercgcom.
It's C-L-A-R-K-E at scoutmastercgcom.
The Scoutmaster blog and the Scoutmaster podcast
are not official publications of the Boy Scouts of America,
nor are they endorsed or sponsored by the Boy Scouts of America.
Come on, let's face it,
they have more important things to do.
No, it's just me talking into a microphone,
trying to lend a hand to scout leaders
and have a little bit of fun along the way.
And before we leave you,
let's hear from our founder,
Sir Robert Baden-Powell.
Sir Robert,
Good luck to you and good camping,
Why? thank you, sir,
Until next time.
Thank you.